تلاء على مختبر بيولوجي في السودان بقوه
السلاح يثير مخاوف من حرب بيولوجيه محتمله
من خلال نشر امراض خطيره وقاتله تضاهي
خطورتها الحروب النوويه وفق بيانات كشفت
عنها صحيفه ذا تيليجراف البريطانيه تحذر
من عصر جديد ومرعب متمثل بحرب بيولوجيه
بعد افتتاح اكثر من عشره مختبرات عاليه
المستوى للسلام البيولوجيه في جميع انحاء
العالم عقب ظهور فيروس كورونا
البيانات اشهرت الى ان الخطر الكبير يكمن
في السودان والمنطقه بعد الاستحواذ على
صرح طبي عريق في الخرطوم عمره 100 عام
شيدته بريطانيا لاغراض طبيه
الخطر القادم ياتي بسبب انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عن المختبر الذي يقع في قلب
المواجهات الدائره في البلاد ما يصعب
الحفاظ على تلك العينات الحساسه والمسببه
لامراض كالحصبه والكوليرا واخرى خطيره
مميته
اكثر من ذلك مواجهات السودان تعقد اصلا
عمليه مراقبه اي تسرب محتمل من المختبر ما
يزيد مخاوف الصحه العالميه التي حذرت من
خطر بيولوجي كبير وهي التي فشلت باداره
ملف وباء كورونا الذي عطل العالم لاكثر من
عامين تقول صحيفه
خلال العشرين سنه الماضيه تصاعد التهديد
البيولوجي واصبح يشكل تهديدا مباشرا
للبشريه بعد تسرب فيروسات او بكتيريا
خطيره عن طريق الخطا او العمد ورغم ذلك
فان الاليه الدوليه الرسميه شبه غائبه وفق
ذا تيليجراف
محاسن حضاره العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات